okay so i read this week that fox news
is now the number one channel in
prime time not just among news channels
among
all channels that's that's pretty
astounding
from someone who remembers when you know
tv was like
nine channels uh that among all channels
including the entertainment ones this is
what people are watching and
i think it was 63 percent of the people
who get most of their news
from fox say that trump has done an
excellent job
fighting govid uh
you know when he loses the election if
he does
these people are not going to believe it
and i remember asking
probably both of you i know i asked you
mayor pete
what are you going to do when he doesn't
go away and back then everyone was
laughing me off and now of course
everyone is kind of like saying yeah
what are we going to do and and they've
gone right to baking it into the cake
that he's not going to leave
and my point was always we need to get
people on the record
now now you have to get the people on
the record saying
this can't happen so what what are your
positions on that
yeah i mean again this is one of the
reasons why we've got to hold
his protectors and his enablers
accountable and one of the extraordinary
things after that lafayette square
episode where he basically politicized
the military was that military leaders
who were involved realized that was
wrong
and apologized whether we're talking
about our institutions
like military or whether we're talking
about elected officials everybody needs
to make clear
now that there needs to be that orderly
and peaceful transition of power i mean
you know and a lot of people used to
roll their eyes every four years when
the inauguration is going on and the
commentators
uh talk about the the transition of
power because it
uh it seems so uh you know something we
ought to be
able to take for granted but this
president doesn't care about
any democratic norm why would he care
about this one to me the only real
solution to that
is to make sure that it's not even close
an election with this president
shouldn't even be within arguing
distance it shouldn't even be
within cheating distance but shouldn't
the democratic party
be able to win by one vote just like the
republican party
why are there's always two rules for
these two parties
we shouldn't have to win big this is
america
we should just have to be able to win
one vote should do it bush won by 537 in
florida and they gave it to him
i feel like well you know how he's
moving the goal right i mean
look i remember being in high school
learning about the electoral college and
thinking well
that's a that's a quirky thing but if it
ever actually overruled the american
people i'm sure they'd get rid of it the
next day
it's happened twice since then and if we
want to call ourselves a democratic
country
it's got to go now the only way to do
that is a constitutional amendment but
there's actually a compact circulating
among the states that if enough states
sign on
promising to give their electoral uh
votes to the person who wins the popular
vote
it'll have the same effect we're not
going to see that happen before november
one more reason why we've got to make
sure it's not even close but i do think
these kinds of structural reforms that i
made the case for in my campaign
whether it's the electoral college
whether it's making sure that our fellow
americans u.s citizens in
d.c uh get a senator making sure the
puerto rico gets real
political representation uh or uh you
know some of the other basic reforms
that we've got to do to our system
in our courts if we don't do that then
we're always going to be chasing our
tail with election results and
just don't reflect what the american
people actually believe yeah
are either of you concerned about q anon
if people don't know what that is
they're
a crazy conspiracy theory group they're
the ones who think that hillary clinton
was
running a pedophile sex ring out of a
pizza parlor
in washington dc i mean it's on that
level and now
you know it it started on the internet
then it
migrated of course to right wing radio
and stuff like that
um and now we're seeing people queuing
on people
in congress someone won the the primary
in georgia
there's going to be a republican
congresswoman who's a cuban on person
they believe a satanic ring of
of you know pedophil pedophilia
fans are running the world and
reptilians and stuff like that
what do we do about that or can we do
anything about that
one feature of the internet and the way
people are getting information now bill
is that negative sentiment and
conspiracy theories
now spread more virulently and
effectively where if you
remember and you you and i are old
enough to remember the days before the
internet
if you had someone with some crackpot
theory they
couldn't find someone else you know like
they were in the town square
right or what not but but now they can
connect with each other
and this is a feature this is here to
stay this is something that we need to
get our arms around as a society because
it's going to get worse when you have
deep fakes and you're able to present
compelling videos of
you me and pete doing things that we
never did and
there's going to be this real question
of what is truth uh
in that kind of era especially now when
we're all sort of interacting via video
i mean we take this video as
as truth and we're having this
conversation but then you know if there
you can present another video that says
something else
so this is something that to me is
fundamental to a functioning democracy
that we are decades behind the curve in
terms of
regulating or figuring out or governing
what the rules are
in terms of hate speech online in terms
of formation of various online
communities
uh and it's getting more and more
dangerous over time it's only going to
continue to get more dangerous as time
goes on
i think there's one other thing i agree
with all of that i think there's one
other thing going on with the conspiracy
theories are actually nothing new i mean
you can go all the way back to
the 1790s and find uh conspiracy
theories about the illuminati it's just
something that that's part of of america
what's unusual is for it to have this
much power for a conspiracy group to
have an ally in the white house or
remember in congress
but i think part of the appeal
especially right now these groups if you
just look at the way they work their
their little codes and stickers and
logos
is they're offering a kind of a kind of
membership
i think they're speaking to a sense of
belonging that people are looking for
anywhere they can find it and if we
don't build real sources of community
uh including you know right around us at
a local level
then really dark and creepy and harmful
things will come in to fill that void i
think we're seeing that right now
yeah i think that's very true
you